- So I'm single.
I'm super fucking single,
I've always been single.
- Oh, I'm very single.
- You're single?
- [Long Haired Man] Oh, yeah.
- Oh, I'm very single.
- How?
(cheesy music)
Hey, I'm Zack and I'm single as fuck.
When you're single, you use online dating.
When you use online dating,
you need a good profile.
But, for some reason, my current profile
isn't getting me any good dates.
So I talked to OkCupid
co-founder Christian Rudder
to find out what I'm doing wrong.
- I think your, actually,
your text is really good.
You know what, we've done experiments.
Your profile text is something, like,
8% of what people take away.
The picture being the other 92%.
- So really, like, it would
be better to spend an hour
doing a photo shoot than it would be
to spend an hour writing my profile?
- Yeah.
It would be better to spend
an hour doing a photo shoot
than to spend 10 hours on your profile.
- So that's exactly what I did.
But I knew I couldn't do this alone
so I sought out the sexiest
man I could think of.
This is Brock.
He has over 1.4 million
followers on Instagram.
And If you wanna know why,
I mean, just look at him.
- How's it going?
- You take incredible photos.
- Thank you.
- Dare I say, sexy photo?
- It's more about, just, what looks good
in the moment, you know?
'Cause most of my pictures are, honestly,
you take one shot right on
the spot and you're like,
"Oh, that's cool, that's it; let's go."
- The reason I brought you here, Brock,
is 'cause I don't know how
to take a sexy picture.
- Okay.
- Do you think that you can help me?
- A hundred percent.
- Let's look for some spots.
Yeah, we'll check it out.
We want something a little
more even in the background
for this shot 'cause you're
gonna be the main focus
and I don't want anything too
distracting in the background.
- I'm the focus.
- [Brock] You're the focus.
- So first photo, what are we doing?
- First one I think we
should do the shirt open.
Yeah, so I had my hair back like that
and it was just a little turn.
- Ahhhh.
- So I'm gonna (laughs), I'm gonna shoot
a couple of these so we can compare.
- I've never had a reason to go like this.
- Do a little stretch out right there.
Like, oh yeah.
- It's like you look so
much cooler when you do it.
Do you ever do the prune trick?
Like, prune.
- I've never heard of that, man.
- You've never heard of the prune trick?
- I've never heard of a prune trick.
- Oh, I got some things to teach you.
Second photo, what are we thinking?
- I'm thinking the pool shot.
- Classic sexy pose.
- [Brock] Oh yeah.
- Oh, it's cold. Ah.
I feel like to be sexy
you gotta be willing
to get a little wet, am I right?
(laughs)
Sunscreen's bleeding into my eye.
Is that sexy?
It stings a little bit.
How do you be natural?
- (laughs) Do you feel comfortable
in that shirt right now?
- No (laughs).
- I say switch it.
I'm confident with who I am, you know,
and it took me a long
time to get to that point
from when I was younger and--
- You were an awkward teenager?
- Oh, yeah.
I might've been as awkward
and skinny and lanky
as you coulda got.
How do you feel right now?
- Really stiff and uncomfortable.
- Let's try more not to
copy the exact photo.
- Yeah.
- Let's do what makes
you feel comfortable.
Being happy and confident
with who you are,
it shows for the camera.
Right there, you're just natural.
You're just thinking.
Just bring that inner
self that you have out.
That was actually good.
- [Zack] Yeah?
- Yeah, check it out.
That's what you're going for.
(both laugh)
- That's pretty sexy.
- It's not bad, right?
- Yeah, it isn't.
- I think we got the shot.
That's something that's so great, too,
is because we're all so different
and there's so many different
people in the world,
you can't just say that there's
one size fits all, you know?
- And here's one with you.
Ahhhh.
Is it possible that I'm sexy
in ways that you're not sexy?
- A hundred percent, 100%.
- No.
- Oh yeah, I'm a little bit jealous.
- I feel like--
- [Brock] I am.
- You shouldn't be (laughs).
I'm, like, looking at this,
I'm like, "Damn Zack."
- Right?
- [Zack] You got, like, some sex eyes.
- Just a couple bros,
taking selfies in the bed.
Crushin' it, man.
- Crushin'.
- [Brock] Crushin' it.
- And I'm like bad boy.
- That's amazing, look at that.
- That's just, like, my
natural sexy impulses.
- I'm gonna have to take notes
from you pretty soon, man.
If anything, you have at least
one fan here no matter what.
I got you.
- Holy shit, Brock.
Am I already sexy?
- You are.
- Did I come in here already sexy?
- You did, you just didn't realize it yet.
- You just had to brush it off.
- Just a little dust, right there pffff.
- Little pfff.
- [Brock] Right there.
- And I'm sexy.
- Yup.
- I didn't need you at all.
- I mean, I don't, I wouldn't go that far.
(cheesy music)
- We did it.
I'm sexy now (laughs).
Looking back, I did a pretty decent job
at recreating Brock's photos but,
Brock's right, I shouldn't
try and be sexy the Brock way.
I need to learn to accept
being sexy the Zack way.
And the moments when I wasn't trying,
just the normal photos,
those are the profile
pictures that will hopefully
get me the date that I want.
Also, I threw in a
shirtless photo of Brock
and me together in bed
'cause, you know, can't hurt.
It is so uncomfortably hot right now.
- It is hot, I don't
know if you could tell
but I'm sweating a little bit.
- Am I sweating?
- I'm sweating, I don't know about you.
- I feel like I'm sweating
more than you're sweating.
- I feel like I look like I'm sweating
more than you're sweating, I don't know.
- Who looks like they're sweating more?
Tell us.
- [Brock] Yeah, tell us what.